bonsoir mais c'est un rassemblement a
donc lieu pour soutenir les palestiniens
et cette fois on le rappelle le
gouvernement et le rassemblement était
bizarre on autorisé par la préfecture
est ce qu'il y a du monde
[Musique]
effectivement stéphanie c'était un
rassemblement autorisé par la préfecture
de police de paris un rassemblement qui
a commencé dans les alentours de 18
heures et qui vient de se terminer il ya
à peu près une vingtaine de minutes
ordre de dispersion c'était 20 heures
qu'on lui pouvait juste derrière moi la
place s'est vidé de ces manifestants et
de ces drapeaux palestiniens il était
beaucoup est revenue une centaine à
l'appel de plusieurs organisations des
partis politiques des associations
notamment comme celle de france
palestine solidarité je suis avec son
président monsieur bertrand elle brode
merci de répondre aux questions des
références bonjour expliquez-nous dans
un premier temps le but de ce
rassemblement aujourd'hui il s'agit
d'abord de manifester notre solidarité
avec le peuple palestinien qui vit une
agression absolument terrible de la part
d'israël
c'est un déluge de bombes qui s'abat sur
gaza qu'il n'épargne aucune
infrastructure civile
aucune maison d'habitation des abords
des hôpitaux mais c'est aussi à
jérusalem d or de fascistes qui attaque
les habitants palestiniens de jérusalem
tous les jours en cisjordanie
ce sont des soulèvements pour protester
contre ce qui se passe à gaza et
jérusalem qui sont réprimées dans le
sang avec 13 morts vendredi dernier et
dont israël même où la population
palestinienne d'israël se trouve
effectivement soumises à des attaques
racistes et des lynchages absolument
terrible vous étiez plusieurs
organisations associations à avoir
appelé à se rassembler ici place de la
république en soutien après la
manifestation de samedi dernier qui
avait été interdit ce rassemblement
autorisé et quel message par rapport à
ce rassemblement souhaitiez vous passez
avec vos des autres associations
gouvernement par rapport à confier à
cette crise qui lie à un treuil israël
la palestine alors c'est un message
vis-à-vis du gouvernement
français de l'exécutif les manière
générale de colère nous sommes très en
colère de la manière dont le mystère des
affaires étrangères a traité la question
dans ses communiqués en voyant dos à dos
le presseur et le primé et nous sommes
encore plus en colère de la manière dont
le président de la république a osé dans
un communiqué le 14 mai écrire
la phrase terrible quand les déluges de
bon ben ça va sur gaza israël a le droit
de se défendre
c'est s'appelle un permis de tuer c'est
ce qu'avait déjà fait hollande en
juillet 2014 c'est totalement
inadmissible et nous sommes très en
colère aussi contre les mines le
ministre l'intérieur
darmanin qui a insulté les militants de
la solidarité internationale et du droit
international que nous sommes pour en or
en disant qu'il s'agissait de
manifestations antisémites
c'est quelque chose qui est inadmissible
pour nous qu'il ya eu des manifestations
des rassemblements dans toute la france
le week-end dernier ils se sont toutes
déroulées sur le moindre discours de
haine
même si l'émotion et la colère sont très
forts donc il faut vraiment d'urgence
qu'à tous les niveaux affaires
étrangères présidence intérieur le
gouvernement français l'exécutif
français révise sa position que vous
avez eu des réponses auprès de la
préfecture concernant la manifestation
de samedi prochain
c'est en négociation ou s'est fermement
interdit alors nous étions en
négociation tout à fait normal pour la
manifestation de samedi prochain qui
serait manifestation très unitaire très
large avec une très forte mobilisation
des syndicats des partis politiques et
des associations comme la nôtre nous
étions en négociation tout à fait normal
ce soir nous avons eu notification
d'interdiction que nous n'acceptons
absolument pas
donc nous ne lâchons rien nous voulons
absolument
manifester samedi prochain dans un cadre
organisé non interdites à dire autorisé
normal où les familles puissent venir
manifester leur solidarité avec la
palestine
je pense que ce n'est pas terminé nous
avons demain rendez-vous avec le préfet
de police et nous tenons nous comptons
bien avoir une autorisation pour
manifester à paris samedi à samedi
prochain à 15 heures comme nous l'avons
pris merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions avant lui
compris les stéphanie un rassemblement
important pour ces militants aujourd'hui
après l'interdiction de manifester un
samedi dernier sont bien décidés à
continuer de négocier avec la préfecture
de police de paris pour pouvoir enfin
organiser la manifestation de samedi
prochain en soutien aux palestiniens
ces bassins szczesny en direct de la
place de la république à paris